[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
how did Greek influence English that is
the question as I mentioned in my recent
video on the Greek language Greek is a
language that has influenced many others
including English the most remarkable
way that Greek has influenced English is
in its vocabulary in my previous video I
briefly mentioned that around 6% of the
vocabulary of English is of Greek origin
but that some estimates reach as high as
12 or 15 percent this depends on how you
measure it you can measure type
frequency the percentage of the total
number of words with no regard for how
often they're used or you can measure
token frequency meaning the proportion
of words in a given speech or text so
words that are more frequently used
count for a larger proportion there's a
huge number of words of Greek origin
that are used in specialized areas of
the sciences medicine and technology
that aren't used very often in regular
speech so if we measure type frequency
the percentage of Greek words will be
higher because less common words are
given equal weight if we measure token
frequency the percentage will be lower
because less common words are counted
less I believe that the figure of 6% is
based on token frequency and the higher
figures are based on type frequency some
Greek words were borrowed directly from
Greek into English some of these were
borrowed early in the history of English
like Church from the Greek word Judea
cone which entered Old English as Kielce
and some were borrowed later in the
early modern English period for example
autonomy this word entered English
directly from ancient Greek autonomia
in the 1620s but a larger number of
Greek words entered English indirectly
through Latin or through Latin than
French for example museum this comes
from the Latin word Moose am meaning
library or studied and that comes from
the ancient Greek word mu say on which
meant place of study library museum or
school of art or poetry and if we go
back even further to the original
meaning of the ancient Greek word it
meant the seat or shrine of the muses
the nine muses were the daughters of
Zeus
the Missoni they were goddesses who
symbolized the Arts and Sciences another
example the word olive entered the
English language around the 12th century
CE II either from Old French believes or
directly from Latin Oliva or Oliwa which
in turn comes from the Greek word Li hua
the word chaos comes from the Greek word
cows and entered English in the 14th
century via Latin then French
catastrophe entered English in the 1530s
from Latin catastrophe from the Greek
word catastrophe which was originally
pronounced as catastrophe meaning an
overturning or a sudden end the word
democracy entered English in the 1570s
it came from the middle French word
democracy which in turn came from
medieval Latin democracia which came
from ancient Greek democracia the word
paragraph entered English in the late
1400s via medieval Latin and French and
it comes from the Greek word pellagra
sauce which was originally pronounced as
para la paz and there are many more
words like this the largest number of
Greek words to enter English were
actually newly created words they were
newly created using Greek morphemes but
their words that hadn't existed in Greek
before that point and then those words
were borrowed from Latin into English
some are formed from only Greek
morphemes for example photography this
word was created in 1834 by combining
photo which meant light in ancient Greek
and the ancient Greek suffix groffle
meaning to scratch or to scrape but
later meaning to write and if you're
wondering how those different meanings
are related to scrape and to write well
think about how people used to write
thousands of years ago they used to
scrape letters into stone tablets
another word xenophobia or xenophobia
this word was created in 1903 from the
Greek root Hinault's meaning alien and
phobia meaning fear other words were
formed from a combination of both Greek
and Latin morphemes for example
television this word was created from
the Greek morpheme T lay meaning far or
at a distance and the French word visual
meaning sight this word entered English
via
another example automobile the first
part comes from ancient Greek autos
meaning self and the second part comes
from the French word mobile which means
moving which came from Latin mobile is
moveable sociology the first part comes
from the Latin word so sheís meaning
comrade and the second part comes from
the Greek morpheme logia meaning
discourse now just have a look at the
morphemes that are highlighted you've
probably seen many more words that
feature these same Greek morphemes there
are lots of common Greek roots in
English for example an throat meaning
man prone or Chron meaning time them
meaning people pet meaning child there
are also many Greek affixes app or n
meaning without by or bio meaning life
or living thing hyper meaning excessive
micro meaning small geo meaning earth or
geography entry meaning against it
suffix that forms adjectives and many
more a huge number of these newly coined
words exist in areas of academia
medicine science and technology because
the huge advancements in these areas
over the past 500 years required the
creation of lots of new vocabulary in
the field of medicine for example Latin
words both old and new be coined ones
were often used for Anatomy while Greek
words were used for the names of
illnesses or specializations a lot of
these specialized words are not used in
daily conversation very often but
without them it would be very difficult
to talk about these advanced fields of
study it's also worth noting that these
words are not exclusive to English a lot
of them are used in other languages as
well when talking about those fields of
study here are a couple of hints on how
to recognize Greek vocabulary most words
starting with pH are Greek some vowel
Spelling's give us a hint like AE or o
eat together if you see a Y between
consonants it's likely a Greek word if a
word starts with any of these consonant
clusters then it's almost certainly a
word of Greek origin some of these
clusters can't be pronounced in English
like PS or PN or GN so the first letter
is dropped in pronunciation
an interesting example back in the 1950s
professor extendo phones Alou toss a
Greek economist and the 75th prime
minister of Greece gave two speeches in
which he addressed the audience in
English but using exclusively words of
Greek origin with the exception of
grammar words like articles prepositions
and conjunctions all of the content
words were in Greek here is a piece of
one of those speeches which he gave to
the International Bank for
Reconstruction and Development
it is Zeus's anathema on our epoch for
the dynamism of our economies and the
heresy of our economic methods and
policies that we should agonize between
the Scylla of numismatic plethora and
the Charybdis of economic anemia it is
not my idiosyncrasy to be ironic or
sarcastic but my diagnosis would be that
politicians are rather crypto plethora
see although they emphatically
stigmatize numismatic plethora energize
it through their tactics and practices
our policies have to be based more on
economic and less on political criteria
now let's break that down a little bit
the first part it is Zeus's anathema on
our epoch this means it is Zeus's curse
or punishment on our time or era in a
typical english sentence you might
expect to see God in this context
instead of Zeus for the dynamism of our
economies and the heresy of our economic
methods and policies here he's saying
that Zeus is punishment is for the
uncontrolled activity of our economies
and our economic heresy meaning
violating accepted economic ideas and
next he'll explain what the punishment
is that we should agonize between the
Scylla of numismatic plethora and the
Charybdis of economic anemia now these
two words here Scylla and Charybdis
these are actually characters from Greek
mythology they are two mythical sea
monsters two dangerous monsters that
it's difficult to navigate between
because if you move away from one you
move toward the other their names here
are indicating two dangerous situations
so the first of those two dangerous
situations is numismatic plethora
numismatic means related to coins or
currency in plethora
means abundance or a lot of to these two
words together mean inflation meaning
there's too much currency in circulation
so
increase and the second dangerous
situation the Charybdis is economic
anemia anemia meaning stagnation or loss
of energy most of the second part is
probably easier to understand but let's
look at one part but my diagnosis would
be that politicians are rather crypto
plethora sk's now this word requires a
look crypto means secrets and plethora
remember that word before plethora which
means abundance or a lot of and then if
that's an ethics showing the doer of an
action so plethora SAR people who create
an abundance of money they create
inflation although they emphatically
stigmatize numismatic plethora although
they speak badly about inflation they
energize it through their tactics and
practices he's saying that politicians
are secretly creating inflation despite
what they say that's just an excerpt but
I'll leave a link to the full version of
the two speeches in the description
below now the irony of me describing
that speech in standard English is that
I probably used a lot of words of Greek
origin myself without realizing it so
the question of the day were you
surprised to discover how much English
vocabulary comes from Greek were you
surprised by any of the examples also
feel free to leave additional examples
in the comments down below
be sure to follow length focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and once
again thank you to all of my amazing
patreon supporters for their monthly
pledges especially these people right
here on the screen thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]